[Music]
today I'd like to talk to you about what
I think is the most interesting the most
exciting and the most fascinating
industry in the world now it's been
flying under the radar for a while but
it's starting to attract some really big
headlines trillions of dollars in
investment and it's projected for
explosive growth now is really the time
to get involved I think it's going to
fine the next 50 years what is this
miracle industry government so I know
what you're thinking I slightly tricked
you there because government is not cool
or sexy well I think it is I think it's
fascinating and I'm interested in how we
do government differently and better
in particular I'm interested in how we
take the experiences of people who
really need government and build them
into the way we design government
services now that's not a new idea
Abraham Lincoln was talking about
government by the people of the people
for the people way back when but having
spent ten years working in and around
government it's my experience that we've
drifted quite a long way from that so
for us the kind of interactions that we
have of government tend to be things
like going to the DMV or registering
with the IRS or going through TSA
processes or perhaps u.s. immigration
and I'm willing to bet that these are
not always the most seamless enjoyable
experiences you've ever had but imagine
how much worse that is if you're 85 or
if you can't read or if you're severely
depressed then having a difficult
experience with government isn't just a
frustration it's a real barrier that
locks you out of the service and into
poverty now I had a vivid illustration
of this when I was volunteering in
Detroit on a program to redesign the
process for applying for food stamps I
was in a rather damp and dingy community
center and the strip lights flickering
overhead in the 8-mile part of Detroit
and I was with a young lady called
Monica and she was trying to go
to applying for food stamps now the
process begins with a 42 page long form
of mind-bending complexity ever written
about font size 1 and it looks like this
moniker was in the 4th hour of trying to
fill in this form and she just reached
the question which says declare all your
liquid assets failure to do so will
result in a penalty and she looks at me
horror-stricken
and she said well liquid assets I've got
some some milk in the fridge now it's
funny right I mean it's funny to us
because we're safe our lives are great
but for Monica if she didn't fill in
this form correctly that meant she
couldn't feed her children now it's not
just a problem for the people use
government services if they don't well
if they're not well designed it's also a
problem for the people are trying to
improve them I had a forceful
illustration of this when I was working
to try and cut crime in West London
we've taken the unusual step of going to
spend 8 days living with a group of
addicts who are in and out of prison
this was a really amazing experience for
me one of the things that stood out to
me most clearly was their attitude to
prison so I assume prisons bad right
prisons bad well they actually seem to
quite like it and that was puzzling to
me in fact when we surveyed them 8 out
of 10 said if I could self-refer into
prison I would do that as in if I could
take a book saying oh I'd like to get
prison now then that's what they would
do I find this really extraordinary
so I said one of the race called Mick
and I said Tim could you explain a
little bit more to me Mick about how
this works I said yeah it's pretty easy
it's basically I like a combination of
freedom in my life just like you do but
I also like structure prison gives me
structure so when you're maybe having a
few chi minh doughnut so you think i
probably need a personal trainer now
well for me when I've had a few too many
drugs when I've been out on the
raspberry much run it too much I think
turn us around and prison is my personal
trainer my my bike right so we're trying
to design a better service for these
guys and we're trying to work on what
would change their behavior and we're so
far off that what we think of as the
stick they think is the carrot I would
never have realized that if I hadn't got
out of my ivory tower and gone and spent
real time with them and so it's not
surprising really the government gets
this stuff wrong because when you think
about it the people who run government
usually have no direct personal
experience of the problem that they're
trying to solve that's not to say that
they're not well meaning or hugely
intelligent they're usually both it's
just to say that the people who work on
bad schools usually went to great
schools the people who work on aging
policy are usually of working age the
people who work on health policy are
healthy and in fact if you want to work
on prison reform it's an absolute
requirement the first thing we check is
that you've never been in prison
so what do we do instead well
we rely on brains it's good to be
intelligent brains are helpful but
intelligence is a complement to good
government it's not a substitute for
direct experience the problem now I know
of what I speak because I was one of
these people I was a technic rat after a
hotshot job in consulting a great
education I wanted to go serve the
government and so I was very excited
when on my first day I got assigned to a
team that was working on homelessness
I thought fantastic this is such an
important issue so I said when are we
gonna go and interview some homeless
people and I was a bit surprised when
the team said well I don't really know
that because we've read a lot of
research we took some academics and
we've also been to speak to the people
in the homeless charities who do the
lobbying on this sort of stuff so like
oh that's great then right brilliant
well I don't think so actually because I
used to I know some of these guys in
fact I was at Cambridge with them
reading classics you know they're nice
people
but they definitely don't have direct
personal experience of homelessness the
real experts on homelessness are
homeless people we're gonna be speaking
to any of them it's no good being the
smartest person in the room if you never
actually go into a room with the people
you're trying to help
so this moment set me searching for a
better way of doing government I please
say I found one and it's actually right
here in Silicon Valley it's to apply the
techniques of design thinking of human
centered design which we use in the Lean
Startup methodology here into government
it's not too complicated basically it's
taking spending time with the people who
you're trying to help and then
co-creating something better
with them now when I say design you're
probably thinking of something like this
or this and that's design this is
designed to what makes Airbnb work is
not the pretty colors it so they thought
really carefully about what would make
for a great user experience for you
and
built something seamless around you
government should be the same so when
you do this you get much better results
first you create a service which
actually works I'm sorry to say that a
lot of government services don't really
work they don't solve the problem they
can set out to try and solve and people
cycle in and out of them over many years
secondly it's usually not cheaper you
spend time looking carefully at what
service people actually want you can
usually cut our load of stuff that they
didn't want and didn't use in the first
place
thirdly this is inspiring work because
design connects you directly back to the
people you came in to public service to
help you get past all that pen-pushing
and form-filling which we associate with
government it really connects you to
what you came into public service for in
the first place
and finally it's respectful this is not
respectful
so don't give into the cynicism about
what government can do it works on
crucial topics like ending child poverty
like cutting domestic violence by
building a fairer society and it does so
with a huge ton of cash we're not
talking about 1% of your corporate
profits here we're talking about really
channeling trillions of dollars to
things that matter if that's so
inspiring I don't know what is so what
can you do
well if you're working government then I
really encourage you to take the time to
find out a little bit more about human
centered design and see if you could
apply it to your work doesn't actually
rocket science it's just about going and
spending some time with the people that
you're trying to help in their office
not in yours and if you don't work in
government well there's still something
you can do stop trash-talking government
is it perfect no could it be better
yes and would it be a lot better if
people who are entrepreneurial who know
about design who know about lean startup
who are bright and talented people like
the people in this room got involved
absolutely so if you want to make your
millions in the private sector great
this is good but if you want to work on
something that really matters if you
want to get up each day with purpose if
you want to build a fairer society if
you want to do the work you were born
for then I encourage you to join me in
this fantastic joint endeavor we call
government and together we can build
government by the people with the people
for the people
[Applause]
[Music]